c'était juste nous deux après le départ de mon
père, je ne pense pas que perdre mon
père ait brisé le cœur de ma mère, mais
plutôt perdre l'amour lui-même, ses mains ont
commencé à trembler au-delà de son contrôle, juste
quitter la maison était difficile,
je me demande s'il peut me donner un coup de main ici  tu
saignes maman c'est Frank il a la gentillesse de
m'offrir un tour
nous ne pouvons vraiment pas t'aider franchement cela
doit arriver
où veux-tu aller chez toi pour
Philippe à la recherche de Frank chambres un
détenu à la prison de Sinfield purgeant 18
ans  pour le meurtre, comment puis-je savoir que tu ne nous feras pas de
mal
Je suis plus fort que tu ne le penses Je ne
doute pas que le
contrôle qui se termine ensemble
bonne plage elle est forte la plupart de mon chemin
avant qu'ils ne pourrissent J'ai une autre idée
Je devrais peut-être y aller  tu devrais rester tu
n'arrêteras pas de chercher Je sais qu'il y avait
deux personnes qui ne pouvaient pas sortir dans le
monde
alors ils ont fait un monde l'un avec l'autre
Je prends 20 ans de plus juste pour avoir
encore trois jours avec toi tu ne peux pas
donne à ta famille oh ouais
toi